ننوه مره اخرى بهذه الاخبار العاجله التي
تابعتها وسائل اعلام تابعه لانصار الله
وقد اذاعتها انصار الله الحوثيين تتحدث عن
قصف امريكي بريطاني يستهدف جبل جدع
بمديريه اللحيه شمال مدينه الحديده وكذلك
هذه الوسائل التابعه لانصار الله الحوثيين
تقول تحريق كثيف للطائرات الحربيه
الامريكيه في سماء محافظه
الحديده الان ضم لنا من صنعاء مراسل
الجزيره محمد العطاب محمد هل لك ان تقدم
لنا تفاصيل اكثر عن هذه التحركات العسكريه
والطائرات التي تحلق فوق مناطق
في شمال في صنعاء
وغيرها نعم اصبح الوضع في الحديده الان
حسب المصادر المحليه وايضا السكان هناك
يؤكدون استمرار التحليق الكثيف لطيران
الامريكي البريطاني على في اسماء الحدي في
سماء الحديده وايضا في مناطق قريبه من
الحديده كالحيه وايضا الكتيب وتستمر الى
مناطق ابعد منها وقد استهدف خلال هذه
المره حسب مصادر اعلاميه تابعه لجماعه
انصار الله الحوثييين جبل
جدع بمديريه اللحيه وهي ساحليه وقريبه من
البحر وايضا استهدف هذا الجبل وقبل ذلك
استهدف ايضا الكثيب في منطقه الشمال نحن
الان نتحدث عن استهداف شمال مدينه الحديده
وايضا جنوبها ونتحدث ايضا عن في بدايه
الضربات الامريكيه البريطانيه استهدف ايضا
مطار
الحديده نحن نتحدث عن استمرار وتكثف على
هذه المدينه الساحليه
ويعتقد التحالف الثنائي البريطانيه
الامريكيه انه من خلال استمرار الغارات
على اهداف تابعه لجماعه الانصار الله
بانها ستستطيع ان تقوض وتضعف قدراته على
الوصول او استهداف السفن ال التابعه ل
التي ترفض حسب مصادر لانصار الله ترفض ا
منعهم للوصول السفن التي تذهب الى الموانئ
الاسرائيليه فهذه العمليه يعتقد
البريطانيون والامريكيون بانهم سيستطيعون
تقويض قدراتهم فيما يؤكد انصار الله بانهم
استمروا لفترات طويله وقد
واجهوا ضربات وغارات اشد واعنف من قبل
التحالف السعيه تقول بان هذه الغارات
والقصف الامريكي البريطاني يستهدف شمال
مدينه الحديده وليس ليس له علاقه بصنعاء
ولكن هل هناك من رد من قبل انصار الله
الحوثيين على هذه الغارات الان يعني هي
محاوله للتصدي لهذه
الغارات نعم حتى الان ليس هناك اي تاكيد
من جماعه انصاره بان هناك رد لكن يؤكدون
بان الرد سيكون قريب وان الرد سيكون قوي و
وحاسم حسب قولهم وان ما يقولون بان امريكا
تجلب على
نفسها بحمايتها للسفن الاسرائيليه بانها
تجلب على نفسها الخسائر من خلال هذه
العمليات التي تقوم بها وان وانهم يجربون
انفسهم خلال الفتره تسع سنوات وان ذلك تلك
المحاولات التي تقوم بها امريكا بريطانيا
لن تقو
قدراتهم
فيما يؤكدون ايضا ان الرد سيكون قريب
ومزلزل حسب حديثهم ولكن الاهداف يعني
حينما تتحدث عن
اهداف لهذا القصف الامريكي
البريطاني هل يوجد اهداف اصلا في صنعاء
بعد تسع سنوات من الحرب هل بقيت هناك
اهداف يمكن يعني التصدي لها او
استهدافها معروف بان انصار الله الحوثيين
في الجبال وفي مناطق يعني لا ي تستطيعون
العثور عليها
ن نعم كما يؤكد انصار الله ان ان ان ما
يتم استهدافه قد تم قصبه في السابق خلال
التسع سنوات وانه الان ما يقوم به الطيران
الامريكي البريطاني انه يقصف ما ما يقصف
المقصوف ف فلن يؤثر حسب حديث انصار الله
على قدراتهم فهم اصبحوا يعني يعملون على
ال الاسلحه والاليات التي يستطيعون نقلها
خلال دقائق او ساعات يعني ساعه و ساعتين
يتم نقل الياته فهم يعتمدون على الحرب ما
يسمى بالحرب الميليشيات او الحرب التي
المجاميع الصغيره
المتوزعة قالوا بان هذا يعني عمل تحذيري
هذه عمليه تحذيريه هل صدر من قبل انصار
الله الحوثيين من الناحيه العمليه استهداف
لسفن في باب المندب او بحر
العرب نعم سمعنا اخبار بانه تم استهداف
سفينه بنفيه لكن لم ياتنا التاكيد من مصدر
من الصدر الرسمي من عند من قبل المتحدث
العسكري من ل جماعه انصار الله منذ ان بدا
التحالف الامريكي البريطاني استهدافه
لمواقع مختلفه جماعه انصار الله لكن
الانصار لا يؤكدون بان الرد قادم وسيكون
حاسم وهم ايضا صرحوا بان المصالح
الامريكيه البريطانيه ستكون في مرمى
اهدافهم فهذا تحذير لانه يعني ذلك ليس فقط
السفن يعني ما لديهم من مصالح في المناطق
المجاوره وفي مواقعهم العسكريه ستكون في
مرمى اهدافهم حتى الان يبدو ان انصار الله
يدرسون
هنا ما هو الهدف المطلوب والذي سيكون ر
ردا قويا رغم التحذيرات الامريكيه
والبريطانيه وهمهم يؤكدون اكثر بان
رسائلهم واهدافهم الان فقط تحذير لكن ما
يقوله انصار الله الان فانهم لن يوقفوا
عملياتهم في البحر الاحمر فان ذلك التحذير
يرمون به عرض الحائط مؤكدين عزمهم لدعم
صمود اهالي غزه حتى يرفع الحصار عنهم
وايضا ينهى ينتهي العدوان
عليهم اشكرك محمد العطاب مراسل الجزيره
وسنبقى على تواصل معك وفق
تطورات الاحداث وعمليات القصف هذه
الامريكيه البريطانيه لمواقع في الحديده